you were the the person that Conor
McGregor picked out of everyone to come
out for his opening song
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe now you can actually get help get
some Dawa and invite him to this - the
purpose of life you know maybe you can
get him now like he invited you you can
invite him for a sit-down and talk to
Conor McGregor
Allah will take who he wants ya Allah
guides whom He wills yes cuz I see I
don't feel like it's my job to convert
any mo no that's none of our job is just
to be the best human beings we can and
to convey you know to try to do our best
compare yeah it's because the very
tenant tenants of Islam are against
everything the world worships the world
worships money that Islam is the chain
that has the truth and has the truths
plural and that's why it's so dangerous
and our culture is built on one great
big lie which is that Jesus Christ was
the son of God right and all the ensuing
lies that can be manipulated out of that
including the very idea that Constantine
had some type of Epiphany
sure he did he wanted to exploit
something and caused a whole series
Elias and that's what's happening Islam
as the truth the person who has a truth
and who also has nothing to lose is an
extremely dangerous person you know and
that's how Islam is perceived in in
Ireland also we suffered from the same
stigma also because of extremists that
we also had extremist because we had a
war going on here and there was a
prejudiced and false idea that if you
stood up at all for Irish nationalism
this meant that you supported terrorism
you know and I think that yours falls me
at my afternoon and I think that Islam
has suffered from the same stigma that
because there are extremists and there
are terrorists it's very easy for those
who want to stigmatize us to say that
we're all terrorists and we all support
terrorism which of course we don't you
know yes so and then I found it what I
was amazed by was the prejudice I found
from women about the fact that I choose
to wear a hijab because I find it
amusing because to me they're saying to
me that oh you're trying to comply with
Eastern men's view of beauty first of
all I'm not look at the stain
we are not beautiful at all and secondly
it's nothing to do about it's a choice
and in fact under the under the Islamic
law might at my age I don't have to wear
a job actually yeah but what amazes me
about it is that these women have their
hair bleached blonde it's got a thing
going across here and it goes down here
their hair their hair itself is a hit
job
they're very hair they're trying to
conform and [ __ ] to Western man's idea
of beauty so I keep bangle if you don't
like your job then shave your hair
because it's the same thing there's no
difference to me
so put on a bangs that the prejudice
about that I find more prejudiced by
wearing the hijab than a but actually
becoming Muslim you know and I so
consequently I love wearing it you know
I feel naked that I'd gone to college
and I had studied all different kind of
things and I had left Islam too laughs
for some reason probably because I have
prejudice you know and then what
happened was an only yesterday and the
Quran did I hear it being said that this
would happen to people who were happen
to me was as soon as I started to read
it and listen to it I realized oh my god
I've been a Muslim all my life and I
didn't know wow yeah I was a more my
life because it's a headspace it's a way
of thinking
Islam is a way of thinking about God
it's exactly what you just said
somebody who believes that nothing in
this world should be worshipped more
than God even though I fail sometimes
I'm not perfect I fail I worry about
money I worry about the teams that we
all worry about I forget sometimes that
I don't need to do that do you mean look
you know so yeah that's what happened to
me what if you say why did you become
why did you decide to revert revert to
the right words yes I was as always a
Muslim and it's very much for me about
the strength of the Scriptures the
intelligence the sheer intelligence of
the Scriptures that I just knew
immediately like know about putting
wrote this book god nobody signed this
to Gabriel or at environment but God
nobody could have created it but God is
so intelligent so you know it's
mind-blowing I can't even find words
it's mine mine I listen to that I'm more
mind blow remember the potato famine
at one point when you had this potato
famine and
the Muslims came and you know lend
support and and the Irish have really
been loyal to that and they respected
that that you know that help and the
Irish are really amazing people we have
the second largest minority if you like
or majority in this country is Islamic
people is Muslims so we have a huge
Muslim culture now you know but it's not
big enough because there's not enough
mosques you know but still did we are
now done God we east when I was growing
up it was only Catholicism here but in
this country now there are many
different religions but after
Catholicism that the strongest and most
fastest growing religion in these
countries as